if you find yourself missing the
destruction of Bad Company 2 but are
willing to have it packaged in a
free-to-play infantry only class based
game then the finals might be your jam
it's not as straightforward as you might
think and there's a lot to know about
how to play well so let's get into it
here's what we wish we knew before
diving into the finals number one move
and Shake in the closed beta before you
even think about mastering weapons just
learn how to move you probably learned
that the hard way from playing games
like Apex Legends and Call of Duty
there's a pretty long time to kill which
could mean dumping multiple mags into
enemy players all while having to evade
during reloads start by getting good at
a combination of running sliding and
jumping also practice getting in and out
of buildings quickly which depending on
class might mean leaping through windows
or just going straight through walls if
you're good with a gamepad as of right
now there isn't much support So dust off
those Mouse and key skills I started
using mostly Gamepad years ago so
apologies you're gonna see me struggle
with the controls a little bit here
number two Turn Down for What when
buildings start dropping with explosions
going off and players flying around on
zip lines it's hard enough to see what's
going on so don't be afraid to turn down
your graphic settings we were just using
a GeForce RTX 2080 super and turned out
everything to medium and then turned off
motion blur that seemed to help the most
with great distraction comes great
responsibility to keep a decent frame
rate number three pick it up or toss it
with all that chaos you might miss that
you can pick up a lot of things in the
environment even things you might not
expect you'll notice the goo canisters
and explosive cylinders that are
scattered around the ground and also
hanging overhead and crates but you can
also pick up things like Planters and
use them as cover more importantly you
can pick up your team's death statues
and then move them inside or somewhere
safer to revive them or if they're in
the floor above you just take out the
floor and revive them where you're at
number four the best defense defense is
a winning if not quite as fun strategy
in the game's current and only mode cash
out a lot of the gear in the game like
barricades and goo don't really make
much sense Until you realize that
matches have a flow between attacking
and defending objectives depending on
what's happening in around at the most
basic level your team gathers cash from
vaults and deposits cash at the cash out
points that's the attack part if your
team makes a deposit at the cash out
point and you find yourself ahead of
other teams on the scoreboard it makes
the most sense to then set up defenses
at that location and just let the other
teams fight it out amongst themselves
you can win a lot more often than you
think by doing that we've seen some
pretty creative strategies from teams
including a Rainbow Six Siege style
outside in defense where instead of
Defending from inside the room you just
stand outside of the room and blow the
walls out and drop anybody who comes in
as well as teams hitting up their own
zip lines with goo bombs to trap chasing
enemy players
if you're ahead as much as you want to
go out and attack more by picking fights
and stealing more cash from other teams
there's some pretty stiff penalties like
a long respawn timer for getting your
team white so on that note if you're the
last person alive in your squad run away
rather than stick around number five get
creative when it comes to attacking or
defending the cash out points there's a
lot you can do when it comes to
attacking and many classes carry
explosives that wreck floors and
ceilings which means either dropping the
cash out Point through a floor down to
your level or opening up a ceiling and
raining down grenades if you're
attacking and notice a box of explosive
cylinders hanging over the enemy team go
ahead and drop it on their head or add a
lot of Goo to the cash station to make
it harder for enemy teams to even get to
it to steal the cash we tried a few
types of traps involving bounce pads and
mines with limited success but what we
learned is that you can stick minds and
bounce paths to walls and ceilings the
most effective traps seem to be a bounce
pad on the floor and a mine on the roof
there's also some classic Battlefield
tricks you could use here like leaving
C4 behind in the box and then clacking
it off when you see the enemies stealing
foreign
number six goo it has more properties
than you might think you can use it to
scale the outside of buildings and hit
objectives from unexpected angles you
can set it as a trap because it burns
you can use it as instant cover to
revive a teammate or glue up an enemy
death statue to make it harder for them
to revive their team the more I play the
more I see people do things that slow
down or impede the opposing team using
Goo so pay attention class number seven
money football like in Halo if you're
running with an objective in this case a
cash cube it's better to throw it ahead
of you continuously than carry it that
lets you use your weapons while you go
you could also save time by throwing it
to your teammates ahead of you
especially if they're on rooftops or you
can Chuck it through Windows right to
them at the cash out station number
eight modifiers if you're running along
in a match and suddenly start jumping
higher that's because the game has
random modifiers this can be at the
start of the game like variations in
time of day or weather or random events
in the middle of the game like meteor
storms damage boost or low gravity these
can play to your advantage or
disadvantage it's kind of fun how random
it is us lots of rain in the arena and
with out comes plenty of noise and
destruction number nine know how classes
work together the heavy class creates
routes through floors walls and ceilings
while the medium class focuses on team
Mobility with zip lines and jump pads
and the light class uses speed and
stealth to maneuver around the other
team overall you do need a mix of class
types to have the best chance to win so
do not hesitate to swap to the one
that's missing in the pre-round let's
get into some more details starting with
the heavy the heavy isn't really that
tanky and it's honestly best just behind
the team they primarily focus on four
ceiling game and create routes through
buildings in either offensive or
defensive ways they carry enough
explosives to level entire buildings
from the ground floor given some time
and that's a totally viable strategy in
closer fights they tend to get
outmaneuvered which is what really
negates their tankiness they can lay
down a lot of fire with their lmg
although the damage output isn't that
impressive and when it runs out they
have a long reload period that makes
them pretty vulnerable alternatively
they can specialize in Close Quarter
builds with sledgehammers and
flamethrowers and that works really well
inside of buildings one very powerful
combo is using a shield to close
distance and then go into town with a
flamethrower their shoulder charge has
more than one use it can create routes
for attackers it's great for
intercepting opponents trying to run
away and it has an extra ground pound
effect if you do it out of a window and
land on the ground it can also directly
kill a weakened player
the medium is there's actually not a lot
to talk about here they specialize in
team Mobility with zip lines and bounce
pads and their shock pedals have the
quickest to revive in the game a good
medium player creates the fastest routes
between cash and the deposit boxes you
can get creative by comboing a zip line
and a bounce pad for very rapid movement
that are just put bounce pads in
unexpected places to throw off enemy
teams it's kind of funny to watch
they can also drop turrets to shore up
defending a cash box if that makes the
most sense
the light players focus on mobility and
can do things like cloak to get around
Behind Enemy teams and cause a lot of
chaos don't be surprised if one comes up
and Shanks you in the middle of a fight
their cloak makes them totally invisible
if they're standing still and one tactic
is to run around a hallway or door and
then just stop and cloak so an enemy
runs right by you this also makes them
great at defending your team's Cash Out
points where they can just stand in a
room being unnoticed and then land a few
grenades in the lap of anyone stealing
from you they can trade that cloaking
ability for a grappling hook to quickly
go vertical and reposition but it all
comes to the cost of being weaker and
head-on fights light players have more
specialized weapons like SMGs Fast Fire
from the hip and dmr's best at long
range that being said if you see too
many light players on your team you'll
probably lose because they aren't that
great on their own they don't have
abilities to help the team and when
attacking they're so fast they get too
far ahead and quickly become outnumbered
that's what we've seen so far from the
closed beta and I'm sure you've spotted
more creative tactics in place so let us
know what you experienced in the
comments below for everyone else fingers
crossed you get into the next play test
soon thanks for watching
hello